and with us today we have Avril
laveser who will be introducing Kristen
you know I said that so many times
really great in practice and then I got
to it and I stumbled over it Avril I'm
so sorry Avril is an associate engineer
at Point Energy Innovations and MEP
consulting firms specialize in highly
cost effective Net Zero Energy and
sustainable buildings she's a Stanford
and McGill University Alum and she's
spearheads decarbonized building designs
across the U.S and has been instrumental
in fostering decarbonization education
at Stanford
avril's going to be involved with the
virtual online workshop on November 7th
and 8th and is here to introduce Kristen
and later she'll be saying a little bit
about the workshop Avril thanks so much
for being here with us today and please
take it away
thanks so much Robin and that was very
close so thank you
um yeah so
I am actually a program coordinator for
the Stanford building decarbonization
learning accelerator and we're putting
on this event along with Robin and her
team
um so the bdla as we call it provides
free teaching resources for building
decarbonization it's all the resources
are prepared by industry experts
Kristen being one of them and we also
provide guidance and assistance to
professors who are teaching the material
as well as hosting events like this one
like the workshop coming up in November
and and several other events
um so Kristen is one of our
collaborators and has really been the
biggest contributor to the embodied
carbon content on our website
um she's also kind enough to often speak
for us at classes and events like this
one
um so thank you again Kristen we always
appreciate it she's a leading expert in
body carbon and buildings and we're so
excited that she's able to join us today
so to give you a little more background
about her she's an associate director of
the San Francisco office of Atelier 10
which is a leading environmental design
firm with offices around the world
she runs their carbon management
practice providing big picture guidance
for Innovative materials on the building
scale she's also involved in large-scale
master plans and other detailed analysis
like daylight optimization and shading
control she successfully LED some of the
firm's most ambitious and complex
projects including the new Nvidia campus
in Santa Clara the San Francisco Giants
Mission Rock Development and is
currently working on the California
College of Arts in San Francisco to
develop a carbon neutral unified campus
she's also an experienced teacher which
I've seen firsthand and has taught
architectural design and environmental
systems and controls at the University
of Oregon as well as many lectures all
over the country
so with what I'm sure is a very busy
schedule we're so lucky that she was
able to join us today so thank you so
much Christian and I'll hand it over to
you
okay great
um thanks Avril uh and thanks Robin and
yeah so I will get us started um I'm
going to present today for about you
know 40 45 minutes and then as Robin
mentioned uh we'll leave some time at
the end for questions so if you have any
um please put them put them in the chat
and we'll come back to them all at the
end
um so I thought I would start off by
just telling you a little bit more about
who we are as a tele A10 we're a group
of sustainability Consultants energy
analysts and lighting designers
um many of us are trained as Architects
some is building science mechanical
engineers ecologists so we have a pretty
broad background we have offices as
Avril mentioned all over the world so we
have 10 Global offices we are founded in
London and then we have three Offices
here in the U.S in New York New Haven
and San Francisco
um and our work and the way we approach
projects is really
um with the design from first principles
and when I say that I mean we look to
really have our buildings uh passively
do more and using active systems um to
do as little as possible so we're always
looking to understand what opportunities
our local climates local contexts
present
um our building types and we work on all
sorts of different building types at
different scales all over the world so
it keeps things really interesting in
terms of uh the role that we play on
different projects
and we really touch subjects across all
aspects of sustainability
um so whether it's working with
Architects to refine building massing
and optimized facades we might be
looking at water cycles within buildings
and master plans to see how we could use
less uh we do a fair amount of
resilience planning and looking at the
ways that that overlaps with resource
conservation and then a whole host of
other things including detailed building
energy simulation to look for ways to
reduce energy use and then a real focus
on healthy buildings so fullness there I
won't read through it
um
and then as I mentioned we have all
sorts of different project types all
over the world uh I've just put a few up
here but we have been recently
um lucky enough to be involved and work
on the Obama Presidential Center
um we worked on the Uber headquarters
here in San Francisco which has a really
Innovative double skin naturally
ventilated facade we've got museum
projects and Airport projects uh Medical
Office Buildings so lots of different
building types and you know I think we
recognize that each of these different
projects
um requires a really different approach
to sustainability so it's something that
we we explore on all of our work
um so today as as Avril mentioned um I
you know I lead our U.S wide
um carbon practice for Atelier 10 and
I'd say it has been the area that we
have been really putting a lot of our
efforts and focus on all projects
um we all understand the climate
emergency that we're in but I think the
the window of time for us to really have
an impact is getting much smaller
um so we have seven years left to avert
the worst impacts of climate change and
when I think about this I I think about
the fact that this really means the
projects that we are beginning to work
on today are the ones I mean we really
need to be solving these issues of
getting carbon out of our buildings
um not in seven years but but now and
you know we've really seen our industry
is very capable of changing
um you know the change that I have seen
in practice in over the last 15 to 20
years
uh has been very rapid and and pretty
you know pretty Advanced and moving
quickly but we need to keep going and we
need to keep going faster especially
when it comes to reducing carbon
emissions
and you know I think in some fields we
sometimes see
um a hope that you know we can still
have carbon emissions and we can offset
them and we will kind of get to
um you know an acceptable place in terms
of of zero carbon but I think what we
really advocate for is you know
of course offsets are not some sort of
golden solution we really need to be
aiming for fewer emissions we really
need to be aiming for zero emissions
it's not quite possible in the current
design world to have zero emissions
related to our building materials or the
operations of our building but it should
be what we're aiming for
and you know our building related carbon
emissions can come from a lot of
different places uh we have
transportation for the folks that are
coming to and from our buildings who
live in our buildings uh there's an
interesting shift happening as we really
expand our electrical vehicle charging
infrastructure that that energy use to
transport people from one place to
another is now part of our building's
energy demand rather than an external
source with fuel combustion Vehicles so
transportation is a big one
uh within operations or the carbon we
use to just run and power our buildings
you know we have electricity we have
natural gas in some cases although
getting to be less and less
um especially in California we have
refrigerants which can have a really
significant greenhouse gas impact coming
from our mechanical systems
and then the water and the waste that we
use and produce uh within our buildings
also have a carbon footprint
um on the material side uh there's an
embodied carbon which means all of the
carbon that was used to create transport
install and replace
um and then dispose of the materials on
our projects uh our industry has become
really well versed I would say in
looking at embodied carbon reductions
for our buildings structural systems and
our buildings envelopes but we are less
well-versed in looking at the embodied
carbon associated with the site of our
building or that infrastructure that
serves our building or the interior
finishes that are often changed within a
building are mechanical electrical and
plumbing systems or even the potential
for Landscapes to sequester carbon so so
there's a huge host of things that
contribute to building carbon emissions
and it's also a huge opportunity for us
to kind of influence carbon reductions
and eliminate carbon in in each of these
these key areas
so I'm just going to go to the one
moment for changing slides here
um
so on all of our projects you know one
thing that we feel really strongly about
looking at is developing a path to
carbon neutrality you know what would it
take to get this building or this master
plan to zero carbon and when we say zero
carbon I mean zero carbon in terms of
operations and zero carbon in terms of
embodied carbon uh so I I'd like to put
up this pathway because I think it
really speaks to the way that we
prioritize and approach uh this path
this
this kind of necessity of getting to
zero so we start on the left
uh with passive strategies you know what
can we do to Leverage The Local climate
uh what can the building form and can
the building's skin do to use less
energy you know how do we Orient the
building how do we design our envelope
based on the climate how do we design
our envelope to open to the exterior and
what benefits can that provide us in
terms of energy use
um then after we're optimizing for
Passive strategies then we're looking at
active strategies having to do with how
we condition the buildings how we light
our buildings
um and all of the equipment that we
house within them
we're also looking to optimize
um the plant from when I say that I mean
we're looking to optimize how we
condition our buildings
um whether there's an opportunity to
capture heat uh can we use shared
thermal plants between buildings of
different types and I'll talk about that
a little bit more later and only after
all of that has been optimized should we
really be looking at renewable energy
and how we meet our demands so we want
to drive it down as far as possible then
look at renewable energy and that is
either on our site you know can we put
um uh photovolta panels on our building
can we integrate them into the building
skin or it can be off-site you know if
we have a site constrained project you
know there are ways that we can invest
in off-site renewable energy to offset
our demand
um we're also looking at reducing
embodied Carbon on all of our projects
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that later and then we've been doing a
significant amount of work looking at
the site in the area beyond our projects
as well
so I think one of the things that I just
wanted to highlight and is that you know
we talked about all those sources of
carbon emissions I would say in today's
design practice
at least at the building scale in terms
of building design teams
you know a lot of the leading
definitions of zero carbon are really
just focused on operational energy use
uh from a to use to power the building
and then embody carbon of structure and
envelope and we're leaving out a whole
host of other contributors so uh we are
very strong advocates for saying we may
not know how to really accurately
quantify all of these other pieces but
we shouldn't leave them out we should be
using best practices and references to
make sure that we're including a really
holistic look at the carbon emissions of
our buildings and not ignoring key
pieces
so there are a few topics that I just
want to talk through today starting with
operational carbon and going to embodied
carbon and there are a number of case
studies I'm just going to use for each
of these so uh the first topic that we
really see is as instrumental in our
zero carbon future uh are is the
advancement of our electric grids to get
cleaner and in order to take advantage
of that uh the movement of our buildings
to all electric buildings eliminating
natural gas
within the building itself and so
um when we're you know we've seen in uh
in California specifically in Northern
California we're seeing a lot of
ordinances passed locally to prohibit
natural gas
um in new buildings and that's generally
prohibiting natural gas for uh for
heating and domestic hot water uses
we're seeing more uh beginning to see it
more for laboratory buildings commercial
kitchens and some of those harder to
Electrify uses but the whole reason
behind this is that we have a pretty
clean
um electric grid in California meaning
that it's it's has a significant amount
of renewable energy content powering it
but that renewable energy and the
um cleanliness of our grid really varies
from hour to hour so while we used to
I'd say in in the past we used to look
at energy use of our buildings on an
annual basis we are starting much more
to look at how our buildings use energy
on an hour-by-hour basis and also
compare that to what the grid emissions
of our local grid is for every hour and
so we're not only trying to overall
reduce our energy demand but we're also
really specifically trying to reduce
that demand during the times when the
grid is the dirtiest
um and so uh that's generally happening
in the uh kind of in California it's
happening in the late afternoon when we
stop producing renewable energy during
the middle of the day coming from solar
and we have a significant increase in
demand in the afternoon
so one of the projects um I wanted to
start with that that really begins to
focus on
on you know how do we not only drive
down our energy demand but how do we uh
begin to control the times at which we
use energy
um is is this project uh designed by
Studio gang it's the California College
of Arts Avril mentioned this during the
intro
it's a it's an Arts Campus located here
in San Francisco
um and it's a new project uh located
adjacent to an existing building and
I'll just show you this image here
so the existing college is within an old
bus terminal and there they had an empty
back lot behind it that they were
looking to build their new campus on
um and this one was a really unique
project because we had the client come
to us and say we want to know what it
takes to get to a carbon neutral project
um so we started where we usually do on
projects which was look at what are the
passive opportunities for this type of
program and this really started with a
programming and space planning exercise
to say for all of the different types of
spaces in this project
um
which need to be conditioned which need
to be indoors uh can we accommodate some
of this programmatic element outdoors
and it was actually something the
college was interested in doing because
there are existing campus had a lot of
outdoor program use so we started to say
it will save us energy to lump together
programs that have similar needs for
lighting and similar needs for thermal
conditioning and that way we can be
really loose about our thermal
conditioning
um in some locations and then provide
use energy to really regulate thermal
conditions in the areas where we need to
I'd say the other thing interesting
thing about this project was
um it's an art school so it has a lot of
heavy making spaces and we knew pretty
well how a typical academic building in
Northern California uses energy we
really didn't have any idea how this
building would use energy it has Kilns
it has glass making equipment it has a
Foundry it has textile production so we
spent a significant amount of time
speaking with all of the leads of the
studios within this college to
understand how their spaces were used
what type of equipment do they have in
there and we did some early stage energy
analysis to really identify what were
the energy drivers for this particular
project so you can I don't know if you
can see my cursor here but um you see
this pie chart everything in blue and
pink in this kind of inner gray ring
that's all of the energy use that's
coming from the equipment in the shops
so over 60 percent of this building's
energy use had nothing to do with how
the building was designed and this was
the really key Insight because it told
us that we one needed to design the
building to be as efficient as possible
but in addition to doing that we needed
to collaborate with all of the studios
to understand how we could gain
efficiency in each of those key areas
while still
making those spaces really usable for
the students and their academic programs
um this caused us to have a lot of
conversations about specifically glass
making
um the way the types of fuel they use
for glass making so it was quite a
different conversation because of the
building's energy use that it may have
been on a typical academic building so I
just say all that to say it's it is
really important and was really
important on this project to understand
what were the energy drivers to know
really where we needed to focus our
design efforts
but if we're going for carbon neutrality
we still need to make the design as
efficient as possible even if a lot of
that energy use is driven by equipment
um so some of the things that we were
looking at um in this project was there
was a ground level plinth that housed a
lot of the heavy making equipment and
then the classrooms could be much
lighter much thinner structures that
allowed daylight throughout that allowed
cross ventilation uh that could be night
flushed in order to cool down thermal
Mass inside these spaces at night
um and then close windows during the day
to kind of keep that wolf inside uh
you'll see exterior walkways wrapping
these buildings these were really key
for a programmatic element to kind of
get visual connection between people
students moving between different
buildings but they also provide really
great overhang and shading on hard to
shade Southwest facades so so there's
kind of Dual Purpose to a lot of the
things you're seeing this is also a
hybrid structure so these uh these small
Pavilions are made out of mass Timber
our team pursued and won a grant through
the state of California for the mass
Timber design so it was a really really
great project in terms of driving down
operational energies and then embodied
energy as well
uh so the other thing that we looked at
then after you know really trying to
hone in on a passive design strategy for
the project
uh was to look at how much renewable
energy we could produce on site so a lot
of this building's um footprint was
really taken up by usable program space
So within the new building we had pretty
limited opportunity for on-site PV but
we had a lot of opportunity for it using
the existing building rooftop so there
was a significant exploration to
understand you know with the structure
of the existing buildings support this
and how could we really leverage all of
that valuable roof real estate uh to
produce as much energy as possible
another aspect of this project which I
won't get into in a lot of detail but um
the project is planning to have a micro
grid meaning that it has a series of
electrical infrastructure that connects
renewable energy generation on site to
on-site storage back to the grid and it
has the ability to island or disconnect
from the grid
um and still maintain some electrical
function
um on without connection to the grid
this was really important for the
college because
they saw a microgrid as a flexible
infrastructure that would enable them to
integrate different renewable
technologies that may not be ready now
but may become ready in the future and
you know this this aspect of that was
important for their for their
educational curriculum and to really use
the building as a laboratory to say
we're not only producing a lot of
renewable energy but we're going to use
it in the smartest way possible at the
smartest times possible
so we did a fair amount of study looking
at not only how much demand our building
had but when that demand was happening
and for the time so we were producing
more energy than we needed could we
store that and use it later in the day
to offset some of those Peak grid
emission times so really interesting
project it was one that kind of changed
the way we even did our analysis uh in
order to get at some of these more
complex issues and so it's one of the
reasons I wanted to share it here
um
I'd say the other thing that we've been
really focused on and we've seen as one
of the most rapidly advancing pieces of
what we do is an emphasis on reducing
and designing to ultimately eliminate
embodied carbon
so as I mentioned before body carbon is
all of the carbon used
for to basically extract manufacture
deliver materials that we use in our
buildings and our projects
and when we're looking at the projection
of new construction you know coming in
the next 10 years 20 years the largest
portion of the carbon coming from that
new construction is coming up front with
the materials that we use to build those
buildings and so when we are really
beginning to talk about you know how do
we avoid critical uh Global tipping
points a lot of our emphasis yes we need
to be on operational carbon but equally
or even more so we need to be focused on
embodying carbon
um so this is just a diagram of all of
those uh life cycles stages of a
material
um you know starting with extraction
ending with end of life and assumptions
about how that material may be disposed
of
um and then you may hear a lot of terms
or you may already be experts in a lot
of these terms
um about uh essentially which stages of
a material
um we may be talking about so you may
hear Cradle to gate meaning we're really
just talking about those product first
product stage emissions
um you may hear upfront carbon meaning
all the emissions that happen before
that material uh goes into the building
um but typically I think we're talking
more and more and should be talking more
about more about whole life emissions
and that's cradle the grave so that's
measurements about how much carbon uh
that material was used to produce that
material and manufacture it estimates
about how much was used to transport it
and put it into place in the building as
well as how many times we think it'll be
replaced in the life of the building and
then broad assumptions about that
replacement as well as what will happen
at the end of its life
you know but it's it's not enough for us
to just quantify this and understand our
material Cycles
um we really need to put this into
actionable uh reduction opportunities
within our design so we can use a tool
called a whole building life cycle
assessment or LCA to evaluate embodied
carbon and look for opportunities for
reduction
but an LCA is not very accurate in the
beginning of a project when we don't
have a design yet we may not have even a
structural system yet but it's at the
beginning of a project where we have the
biggest impact to reduce embodied carbon
We could decide to reuse a building
instead of building one new We could
decide on a structural system that has a
significant impact on reduced embodied
carbon and material efficiency and so um
it's a bit of it's a bit of an
interesting challenge when you know the
tools that we have to evaluate embodied
carbon are very accurate when all the
decisions have been made so we need to
be a lot more Nimble and we need to make
smart decisions up front uh based on
high level analysis based on experience
and based on things that kind of get us
moving in the right direction in terms
of embodied carbon reductions
and there's a lot of different ways we
could reduce embodied carbon I would say
the best in the thing that we should
always be seeking to do is to Simply use
less
um
so that may be a smarter structural
systems that may be not building a
building from scratch and maintaining
structural systems for reuse it could be
picking better materials so that could
be subbing out you know a different
insulation type or selecting a different
structural system
um or it could be looking once even
we've decided on what material we're
using looking for the best product that
has the lowest embodied carbon footprint
and so you know in a lot of our work and
a lot of our conversations
um
when we're talking about low carbon
structure uh
often Mass Timber comes up as being
synonymous with low embodied carbon and
so we you know we were curious in terms
of
if we were you know there's a lot of
different ways that we can design
building structure broadly we've done
some studies
uh these are based on U.S wide averages
the steel frame structure versus a
concrete structure versus a mass
temperature structure and you know I
think the question of
which is more efficient and if you
highly optimized concrete or steel based
on today's optimization options or even
based on what we see will happen in the
future kind of which of these options is
best is is Timber still lower embodied
uh carbon option
and so these are all based on U.S
averages so I should say these results
would vary depending on location uh
globally uh even depending on location
in the United States uh but generally
what we found was that um uh in today's
market Timber is is still better
um from a carbon perspective but only if
it is sustainably harvested and so we
could go we could probably have another
entire five webinars on sustainably
harvested Timber
um but you know just to call out here
that the bars you're seeing on the right
represent a mass Timber building those
hatched areas represent the benefit that
we get from the carbon that is locked
into the strut the structure the carbon
that has been sequestered by those trees
when they were living so we are showing
those and demonstrating those in these
reductions
um because if we have a sustainably
harvested Timber building
we can take credit for the fact that
that carbon is locked into the material
if that Timber is not sustainably
harvested you see that these you know
these bars begin to look very similar to
the steel and the concrete structures in
terms of carbon emissions so sustainable
harvesting critically important
um and then you know in addition to
those early conversations about what
type of structural system uh there are
some carbon reduction opportunities that
we've seen that you know they hold true
across the board they are things we
should always be looking at
um
we should always be looking at concrete
optimization we should be looking at our
steel procurement and is that steel
coming from regions where we have um
clean grids that are being used to power
the manufacturing plants making those
steel uh rebar same same situation is
steel our interior finishes become
really important because they are
they're very often switched out in a
building so while you may
um so while The Upfront uh carbon of
your building may be predominantly
within the structure those interior
finishes are going to be changed out
multiple times during that building's
lifespan and it means overlooking at the
holistic carbon they have a big impact
insulation matters facade materials
matter
so we just like to show these because we
don't need to do any analysis to know
that these are going to be big drivers
and to start to have early conversations
about them with our design teams
um here's an example of some of a
project where we were looking at um
different concrete optimization for
different types of concrete and
applications of concrete within a
project
I would say same thing here
um one of the biggest things we can do
is get uh
get your clients and Structural
Engineers
um and Architectural design teams in the
room in the beginning if you have a
Contractor on board also the contractor
having these conversations about all the
different concrete mixes on a project
because sometimes we can make schedule
changes to get lower concrete options
sometimes it's different admixtures
um but there there can be different
approaches to really optimize and drive
down our carbon emissions of our
concrete and a lot of times those
conversations should happen very early
on because they may not add cost but
some may add time or they may not add
time and we can do this in a really
smart way
where we're kind of hitting those
reductions
the conversation has to happen early
early then the next thing we generally
do after looking at these big ticket
items looking at concrete we will start
to do an LCA or a life cycle assessment
later in the project to understand what
are the carbon drivers for this
particular project and where do we focus
our effort we also begin to then test
carbon impact reduction measures so on
the left you see a building profile
that's looking at uh it basically breaks
down what how much of that embodied
carbon is coming from Foundation versus
parking in this case versus structure
versus building skin and interiors and
then it further breaks that down so we
can see you know what are those main
drivers here in this case concrete and
steel are huge but also fluorine and
tile are big within Interiors because of
how often they're replaced
um
so we recently uh worked on a project
this is a building designed by Som it's
the new San Mateo County headquarters
um would be the first Net Zero Energy
Civic building constructed with massive
timber in the U.S and this project
achieved an 85 reduction in embodied
carb structural and body carbon versus a
typical Baseline project and this was
really coming from so this was Som and
their internal structural team
um not only from the fact that it was a
mass Timber project sustainably
harvested but also from the fact that
they were involved in a lot of material
optimizations for their structural
system throughout so both the use less
and use better materials um definitely
applied in case
um but I think you know one thing I
mentioned before was that if we really
are going to limit our embodied carbon
footprint it's not just going to be
through designing better new
construction we really have to take a
serious look at opportunities for
building reuse and and should be reusing
buildings you know more often to the
greatest extent possible and really
maintaining all of that embodied carbon
that's already locked into a structure
um so this is a project that our East
Coast team recently worked on
it was a re-skinning of an existing
building structure
you can see here the breakdown of
embodied carbon
um for a baseline a similar Baseline
building so this is if we were to
construct that building from scratch
today what was it what would its
embodied carbon footprint look like
you see a significant amount coming from
the structure specifically steel metal
deck and steel framing
um and then it's also a significant
amount coming from uh curtain wall and
then Interiors but really looking at
this huge structural piece and looking
at the opportunities that there are to
in reusing that structure to reduce
embodied carbon over a new construction
building
um so this was
an analysis that we did looking at you
know if we had built that building for
new what would its um embodied carbon
footprint be versus if we designed to
renovate the building
um saved we saved over 70 in terms of
embodied carbon just by reusing the
structure uh and then with additional
carbon impact reduction measures reduce
that a little bit more but I think the
key thing here is reuse blows any other
carbon impact reduction measures out of
the water uh and is really effective
strategy
um
we worked on not a similar project but
we worked on an Adaptive reuse project
here in San Francisco uh this one was
with Swig and Gensler were the design
team on this one you can see the
existing building on the left uh you can
see the the new building rendering on
the right but this this was recently
completed in the last few years
so this is a project called 633 Folsom
um there was an opportunity when this
building
um became vacant to do a renovation
project that not only kind of renovated
the existing facade and improved some of
the connection to street but also
created an addition that really had a
very strong emphasis on Health and
Wellness in the employee experience
inside the building
so one of the things that the design
team was very focused on was developing
an Innovative way to reclad the building
which would help with that improved
experience so they wanted to bring a
significant amount of daylight into the
Interiors
um they wanted to enable a lot of the
enable views out because there are some
incredible views from this building but
they also wanted to do that without you
know bringing in a lot of heat and a lot
of Blair into the building
so the design team was um developed this
this design strategy of of these
L-shaped hoods around each of each of
the windows you can kind of see these
the new envelope getting applied
um and then this shot up to the existing
floors and then the new floors being
added on top
and so optimizing that fin shape was
really important but one of the
um one of the really interesting things
out of this work was to look at the
extent to which those fins
um
enabled the views to be maintained and
so this was this became a really
important part of the project discussion
which was if you didn't have the fins
you would need during certain times of
the year on each facade to kind of draw
your window blinds your interior blinds
to prevent direct sun and glare from
coming into the building
with the added fins those fins blocked
uh direct sun for a number of hours and
allowed you to leave the blinds up
longer and so we did an analysis for
each of the building orientations to
look at how many additional hours could
you keep the blind
um keep the blinds up uh from you know
how did you gain that from adding these
fins and so these are hourly charts
which will get every occupiable hour of
the year and then the areas in red are
showing how many hours you gained back
uh that you don't have to pull your
blinds by having these hoods
um and this you can kind of see the
result of that here uh so this is a
daylight uh mapping within the interior
floor plan but also the things we're
calling out here are the additional
hours that you can maintain your blinds
up have you out
um by adding the exterior uh fins there
and so
um this project ended up I you know I
think it's usually wild success story
it's a beautiful project I love driving
past it or biking past it when I'm down
um down in this part of the city uh but
it also was the um one of the largest
office leases at a time you know when
when leasing buildings was becoming
really challenging so I think a lot of
that attention to health and wellness
and experience of occupants
um really
paid off in this kind of reinvigorated
building and I think I just I like to
show this one because it's not all about
embodied carbon
um there are certainly other benefits we
get from building reuse and some really
innovative ways that buildings can be
reused and reimagined
um so we've talked all about buildings
until now uh I want to talk a little bit
about what we would say beyond the
building
um what are our sites what are our
Landscapes uh able to contribute to the
low embodied carbon uh conversation
um so this is all work that I'm showing
is associated with climate positive
design challenge
um so this this is a group founded by
Pamela Conrad who is formerly at CMG
Landscape Architects these are all of
their diagrams uh I can't take credit
for any of them they are beautiful
um but we helped
Pamela and her team develop uh and flesh
out the Pathfinder tool which was an
early tool for Landscape Architects to
evaluate the relative embodied carbon
emissions of their projects and
you know I think one of the first
conversations I had with Pamela she said
um you know Landscape Architects have
these really we have a really unique set
of tools in our toolbox you know we
we're specifying materials that have
embodied carbon Footprints but we are
also specifying vegetation and trees and
grasses that have sequestration rates
and so the climate positive design
challenge is really challenging the
landscape architecture Community to
design projects which over their
lifespan
um uh sequester more carbon through
vegetation than they emit in terms of
their initial materials
um and I think one of the really nice
ways that they've been talking about
this is to illustrate
uh projects
not only the embodied carbon or the
holistic carbon impact of you know
adding more vegetation adding less
Hardscape but also the the kind of
experience of what it needs to be in
that place and I just I love these
diagrams because they show not only
um metrics around carbon emitted and
carbon sequestered but they also show
like a fundamental shift in what it
means to be in that space and what that
space feels like and I think the more
that um
as you know the more nuanced we can be
and the more that we can be talking
about
um these sort of co-benefits is the
design Community you know the more
successful I think will will really be
in driving down carbon impacts of our
project so that kind of brings me to the
last point which is
um
it's not all about carbon you know I
think reducing carbon emissions is by
far the most pressing Global issue of
our time but there are lots of other
factors that that designers and design
teams and clients are having to balance
and so
you know we're very interested in the
co-benefits of lower embodied carbon
lower operational carbon design
um sometimes this is a slide we created
when we were you know talking about
well what else do you get out of
reducing embodied Carbon on a building
um there was a question of do the
manufacturers who are reducing their
embodied carbon of their products uh are
they also do they have a better emphasis
on healthy materials are they focusing
more on that are you getting kind of two
for one when you're looking for folks
who are responsibly manufacturing things
and getting healthier materials and a
lower body carbon
we've had a lot of conversations about
cost
you know this is an area where cost
reduction and embodied carbon reduction
can go hand in hand in terms of
structural efficiency you know there are
opportunities to really be
strategic and efficient and structural
design though should reduce cost
materials and embody carbon
um
can I think that the questions of
especially when we're talking about
landscape sequestration can increasing
the sequestration of our landscape
also have an ecological benefit to
supporting local habitats and then how
does our increased emphasis on reducing
bodied carbon also really drive a change
to how we treat materials at the end of
their life so now the fact that we are
thinking more about the end of life of
our materials
you know can we drive into I think we
hear the term circular economy a lot I
don't know that it's always happening in
many places but but can we drive to a
place where we are able to re have a
market for reuse materials we are
designing for end of life
um for certain building structures so I
think they're all things that we need to
be
headed towards
um
you know and then I I think the other
thing that we've been focused on and
that the industry I think is is
beginning to focus a lot more on is the
fact that um
in beginning to look at the lifespan of
our materials and where they come from
and how they've been extracted and how
they're getting manufactured and getting
all of these details and this insight
into this whole lifespan gives us an
opportunity to look at all of the other
ecological and human health impacts of
materials
so this is the aia's architecture and
design materials pledge
um
I it has a a Kind of Wonderful series of
um things that we should be considering
when we Source materials like human
health like social health and Equity
like ecosystem Health like the economy
that we're driving and climate Health
the one related to carbon emissions is
just one of these and so I think it's a
good reminder that like yes carbon
Productions and we need to make sure
that we are also looking at all of these
other pieces so
um
anyway I think maybe we're getting the
time so I will I'll end there
um and I really appreciate you listening
today and looking forward to answering
questions
thanks so much Kristen it was so
interesting insightful and I really love
how you kind of covered it souped nuts
I'm like it's not just about what you're
doing with the building but where the
materials are coming from and how
they're being sourced and how important
that is so thank you for that
um so I see the first one is
um how optimistic are you based on the
usage trends of using building
decarbonization techniques to alleviate
the energy crisis what kind of uptake is
happening
yeah I think I mean this is a really
good question I tend to be optimistic
because I think we need to be optimistic
I think we need to continue to throw
everything we have at reducing carbon
emissions
um
but you know I think
there is a recognition that buildings
are just one piece of this so I am
really optimistic about the the
advancements we've seen in in building
decarbonization
um I I think it needs to happen much
more quickly
um you know we're in a bit of a bubble
out here in Northern California where we
see really rapidly moving
um regulations to you know uh to elect
or
Electrify a lot of our new buildings to
Electrify uh existing buildings to bring
renewable energy to our grid region and
so I think it is a good a good model and
where I hope they'll see everyone else
moving towards
um
but you know I think
we have an opportunity through buildings
and through design to have the broader
impact that is really necessary for us
to
um alleviate the carbon crisis and when
I say that I mean
in electrifying our buildings in uh
seeking Greener energy sources you know
we can have a kind of feedback loop to
local grids to local utilities
um and some of that you know often
investment in off-site renewable energy
can support the Renewable Energy Mix
that our local our local grids and
utilities want to keep moving
um I would say are buildings and smarter
time of use and ability to kind of
control demands on the grid can help
support that transition to a renewable
uh a supplied grid
um I'd say the choices we make in our
materials and asking for transparency
can send signals to manufacturers to
um you know ask them to do better ask
them to design for lower carbon you know
so I think it's our buildings are
important but it's also all of the
industries that our buildings connect to
and the ways that kind of even small
changes within buildings if they're
happening enough over the built
Community can have these larger impacts
on Industries on Transportation on
utility grids and I think that's where
we really that's where I have optimism
that you know we have the ability to
kind of make a change there
um see then the next question are there
any limitations or disadvantages to mass
Timber
um yeah it's a good question you know
Mass Timber is not for for every project
they're
uh there are regions where you know Mass
Timber may not be the lowest embodied
carbon option because it's getting
trucked in and that can be hugely carbon
intensive so knowing your region knowing
where your materials are coming from
knowing if they're sustainably harvested
is is a first
um you know there are certain uh
dimensions of structural grids that you
can and cannot achieve in Mass Timber
there are some
um you know some local jurisdictions and
fire codes you know may not be
comfortable with mass Timber and will
inquire require things like
encapsulation and require you to cover
the chambers then you're adding more
material back so
um I guess the question
is you know it does one does need to be
very aware of their their local context
and some of the nuances around
regulations material sourcing uh program
type and programmatic needs to really
determine as a team if it's if it's the
right solution for a project because
um it's it's not a one-size-fits all
uh
solution
um
okay there was a question San Francisco
is a seismic area region do the
materials abide by the seismic codes of
construction uh yes I mean where where
these projects are being designed in
seismic regions here in San Francisco
yeah those structural systems are are
being designed to code to accommodate
the fact that we are in a seismic Zone
um okay let's see
there's a question what are your
thoughts about how existing residential
buildings can use retrofitting and
Technologies to decarbonize uh here in
New York City relative to local law 97
there's a big Focus but feels like
limited applicable Solutions
yes this this is a really good question
um I'm not sure I have a great answer to
it
um and for those who don't know
um local law 97 in New York City uh is a
it's a really Advanced um uh kind of
local requirement for uh essentially
aimed at existing buildings and the
carbon emissions of existing buildings
in New York and essentially
um looking at their their carbon
emission
um intensity and kind of having a Target
by which you know above which they will
be charged for exceeding car certain
carbon emission intensities so it is
really driving
uh Beyond building codes focused on you
know efficiency and new construction and
retrofits it really is starting to drive
and tackle that issue of existing
buildings which is where you know in
terms of our built environment a lot of
our carbon is really tied up in so so
it's it's a very Progressive law um
and I think we'll you know we'll see how
the implications play out but is really
trying to incentivize building owners to
um uh do better in terms of their
building performance and operations
um so you know I think
My Hope here is that a law like that
really does Drive where we have gaps in
technology to meet those demands kind of
drives Innovation and drives a market to
respond to some of those gaps and you
know beginning to I think it'll be a
combination of you know incentives
uh to begin to incentivize homeowners or
multi-family owner homeowners provide
some funding to kind of make those
retrofits so there's like the carrot and
the stick you get the Curative
incentives to do the better thing when
you're retrofitting
you have the stick through local law 97
to kind of penalize larger building
owners if they are if they do have high
carbon emissions so
um you know I hope that drives some some
Innovation and solution so kind of a
non-answer but uh hopefully those are
things that are heading the market and
to write in the right um Direction
okay let's see so and then the last
question I see here is in your projects
do you estimate the total price of
carbon you've reduced what reference
price do you use in dollars per kilogram
of co2e okay this is a really
interesting question
um
we
we are always talking about
um what the right way to do this is and
uh I would love to hear others
experience on this
um we do often estimate the total
reduction in carbon
um we don't always estimate the price
and I think their reason for I would
should say the other thing we do look at
is
um dollars invested per carbon saved and
so sometimes we'll look at that metric
to say you know where can we most
effectively if there is a premium for
some of these strategies
um where can we most effectively invest
that money to get the largest carbon
reductions
but yeah we've been we've been looking
into this question
um you know we found different companies
are
may actually have their own internal
pricing or carbon
um so we've seen companies use something
you know use like a shadow price of
carbon to estimate the at a corporate
level to estimate the the kind of um uh
risk of higher carbon emissions in
Future Future Holdings or Property
Holdings
um we've seen some companies just set an
internal price of carbon based on what
it would cost them to offset that carbon
so companies that have committed to
carbon neutral operations you know do
pay a price to offset their carbon
sometimes that is a real price that
they're including in planning efforts
um we've seen companies Microsoft is an
example that has an internal carbon tax
so they're using
um they're using uh charging folks or
departments who use kind of more carbon
and that money is going back into a fund
to fund efficiency measures so we don't
often do this because the price varies
depending on who we're working with but
we do often try and ask especially for
our clients whether there is a cost of
carbon that they're using for their
planning purposes
okay so I think that's the last question
and we are right at two that was great
that was perfect timing
yeah
yeah thanks so much Kristen we really
appreciate it that was that was really
comprehensive and wonderful and you did
get through all the questions so thank
you so much
yeah thanks everybody
thank you
bye everyone